the Great Canadian AB quiz we're going  to show you oh no some Canadian app says  can you hold the ABS up you just name  the actor  [Music]  goodnight oh my god dating actors wow  those are pretty big art that narrows it  down  um is that Ryan Gosling who do you guys  think that it's Gosling Ryan Gosling  yeah can you play like your Photoshop is  that house that's Ryan Gosling all right  one Abdi when I got here to go  that's a Canadian epic about the  Canadian I have a light unik I'm just  thinking I don't know that one about the  Canadian this is another Ryan that Ryan  riddle has Ryan Reynolds ran ran ran  home and then oh my god right what do we  have right here ooh Justin Bieber haha  what do you that's me yeah just you  Dancing's enough to distract the entire  sorority I don't know about that I got a  little work very close  Justin's event as much hair as Seth  Rogen's what's weird is that's not paint  that's what I look like